N
CROSS-EXAMINATION FOR EXAMPLE IS
IN A TRUE MS. HUTCHINSON THAT
YOU WERE INSIDE THE SUV WITH THE
PRESID
YOU DIDN'T SEE WHAT HAPPEN.
YOU DIDN'T HEAR WHAT HAPPENED.
SO YOU REALLY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
OCCURRED IS FOR OTHER
ALLEGATIONS AND STATEMENTS THAT
SHE ALLEGEDLY HEARD.
WAIT A MINUTE ISN'T TRUE THAT
YOU JUST SAID YOU WERE IN THE
GENERAL VICINITY AND YOU
OVERHEARD THE STATEMENTS TO THE
EFFECT OF.
ISN'T IT TRUE YOU DON'T KNOW
PRECISELY WHAT HAPPENED?
THAT WOULD BE A DECENT
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
THEY IGNORE THE DONALD TRUMP.
>> Hannity: THE FIFTH PERSON
WAS A GENERAL WHO BEEN UNABLE TO
INTERVIEW THEM WITH SOME CLOSE
TO HOME DID ASSURE ME THAT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF THE CAPITAL DID COME UP
BETWEEN HIM AND PRESENT
DONALD TRUMP.
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
AUTHORIZED GUARD TROOPS IN THE
DAYS LEADING UP.
DON'T BE EXCULPATORY WILL NOT
DESTROY THE ENTIRE NARRATIVE
THIS COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO
PUSH?
>> YES IT WOULD SEAN NONE OF
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN ADMISSIBLE TO
SEE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT'S ONE
THING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE DONE SINCE
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN IN OFFICE.
THIS IS ACUTE TO MERRICK GARLAND
TO PROSECUTE DONALD TRUMP, NONE
OF THIS WILL BE ADMISSIBLE.
THEY KNOW THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS ALL HEARSAY AND I
LET THE SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
ARE COMING FORWARD TOO SAYING
THAT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN, DID NOT
HAPPEN WE WANT TO TESTIFY.
WE SHOULD'VE BEEN HEARD HEARD
EARLIER WE WEREN'T.
HER CREDIBILITY IS SHOT.
NOTHING THAT SHE COULD SAY COULD
BE TRUE.
NO ONE WOULD TRUST IT ANYMORE.
SPEW 120 SECONDS GREG THE
EVIDENCE OF THE TROOPS BEING
AUTHORIZED BY THE PRESIDENT?
>> YEAH ABSOLUTELY ANY
RESPONSIBLE COMMITTEE WOULD'VE
INVESTIGATED THAT.
ONE THING ABOUT LIZ CHENEY SHE
COULD'VE JUST PICKED UP THE
PHONE AND TALK TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY SAW AND HEARD WHAT
HAPPENED IN WOULD'VE BEEN TOLD
ACCORDING TO FOX REPORTING THAT
IT'S ALL UNTRUE.
MAYBE SHE ALREADY KNEW IT WAS
UNTRUE WHICH MEANS THAT SHE WAS
HIDING EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE FROM
CONGRESS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SPEW ONE I HOPE THEY SENT A
PRESERVATION LETTERS FOR EVERY
PERSON I COMMITTEE EVERY STAFFER
ON THE COMMITTEE BECAU